yeah leaving new jersey yeah i was i was
thinking about this when i saw your
your your page you're saying make new
jersey great again and it made me feel
kind of bad
you know because i'm i'm out i'm getting
out of here dude i've been
i've been here for um about six years
no no about five years now been in new
jersey for five years
and i've been slowly building up my
business it's doing better than ever and
i'm sitting here with like the lockdowns
here you know the adolescent guys just
down the street right right i know him
nah i i don't have anything to do with
this guy and his
his edict and you got cops that are
enforcing the stuff he's asking for song
it's it's not just that south jersey is
a peninsula
we got we got crazy riots and everything
i don't want to be i don't want to be in
the past
you know what i mean so it's partly that
too so i'm gonna go inland i'm gonna go
to the middle of nowhere
but like north dakota or something not
that far
down the east coast i'm just gonna move
inland you know about in an hour or two
or whatever
yeah but then i i see i see your thing
you're like make new jersey great again
and i'm like
you're sticking around i mean you know
what's funny about you saying that is
you know when i was in the military i
was stationed in texas and in my in my
opinion there's no place more american
than texas
you know i absolutely what bro i love
texas man
and the funny thing is is going out
there when i was when i was gonna get
stationed in texas the first time we go
off base
and we're walking around this is in uh
wichita falls texas right
me and my friends are going out we're
looking for a uh i think it was like a
video game store or something we were
going to we're walking and where we're
going through
we're like in the middle of nowhere like
some podunk cornfield type place right
and there's like this guy sitting in
this dilapidated house
just chilling there with bloodhounds and
like just totally stereotypical yeah
yeah yeah
i'm like was that a rocking chair with a
shotgun might as well have been you know
so it's me black dude a hawaiian guy and
uh
and a samoan guy right and an hispanic
guy so me uh so so black guys
hispanic guy samoan and hawaiian we're
walking down this block all of as brown
as can be
you know walking down the block and we
look at this guy this guy's looking at
us we're like oh man we could smell
something burning so we're like man
they're probably like you know burning
the cross or something in the backyard
you know what i mean
and i'm like yo let's just go back to
base or whatever right and the guy's
like hey man y'all from around here
i don't say anything you know but the
smallest guy with us is the samoan guy
he's like yeah yeah we're looking for
the store or whatever's like hey why
don't y'all come out back
you know we're cooking a pig back here
and we're like no no no we're good we're
working we're good
he's like oh y'all look hot y'all should
get some lemonade and we're like nah
we're good but then my friend's like oh
no let's go so he starts walking and i'm
like oh my god and i'm like you know
never leaving the airmen behind right so
i follow right behind them
you know we go back there some of the
sweetest people in the world i've ever
met yeah these guys man
you know i'm thinking in my and i was
afraid to come to texas at first i'm
like man they got a bunch of cowboy hats
shotgun totin
redneck racist kind of people and no not
at all
you know some of the the nicest people
in the world we had a great time had a
couple of drinks
and all that you know i experienced more
racism here than i did in in new jersey
than in texas you know i think it feels
like it's like the pendulum swung
and so where you used to have the you
know the racists in the south and
everything it's swung now to where
they'll treat you like a normal
regular regular person but now on the
left
they've gone so far in the other
direction they
you've got white progressives that
scream in the face of minorities racial
slurs
right like they think they're doing
virginia right now like that you see
that video of that white woman
she's holding up the signs screaming at
the black female cop like screaming
like just haven't seen that it's it's
hilarious because she's holding up a
sign
while she's screaming at a black woman
and it's like dude
but the sign on the back is fragile and
i'm like that is the perfect image of
white fragility
but this guy's filming and he goes don't
you think it's inappropriate for you as
a white woman to be screaming at a black
lady about racism
right and she's like no because i'm the
only one who can do because i have to do
it and she's part of the system
they're nuts that's crazy that's the
craziest thing to me
i it feels weird that like i was kind of
like what i was trying to get up before
about you being a republican
is that they they kanye west was talking
about this
they told him you better be a democrat
you better support democrats otherwise
i'll destroy your career
right like they have a stranglehold on
minority communities right me coming
from
the south side there's every reason that
everyone in my area everyone i know
should be
a democrat just absolutely oppose the
republicans not our team
and now i'm talking to people from my
neighborhood and
they're all you're all wearing mega hats
no secretly voting for trump right
that's what it's like in patterson too i
would say so i i did
on my main channel today i said trump's
second agent second term
uh agenda list that's it enough for me
like i'm gonna vote for the guy
and there's like congressional term
limits and ending the wars i was like
i'll take it man
at this point it's it's a combination of
trump has improved enough for me
he did this speech at the rnc where he's
like i'm not going to say mean words
about hillary because they're going to
get mad at me and i was like
i actually really liked that he did that
he's like i'm not going to touch with an
sc i'm not going to say the word and i
was like
that's an improvement that's an
improvement and but then but then he did
try to end the war
i talked about all the time because it's
big for me that's why i'm really
impressed with you saying
you know when it came to libya you were
questioning this stuff because i think
that's one of the biggest problems we
have
where we're constantly you know
internally we argue about all these
political issues but most a lot of us
have talked about for you know we need
money for this we'll tax the rich i'm
like
we stopped blowing up the people in
foreign countries starting these wars
and we'll have money left over we can
bring it back here
exactly so anyway trump's improved but
also the democrats are just getting
worse and worse and worse
the riots the the the insanity i am sick
and tired of the lies
it's just it really is you know i was
talking i got an email from some dude
who said
he's in europe and when you turn on any
european news outlet
the narrative is always far left that
trump is evil
he's a dictator peaceful protests are
marching and trump's is beating him
and then he's like but then i go on the
internet and i watch what's actually
happening and it makes me angry
so so for you know it's like i wonder if
the pendulum has swung you know you tell
the story about a guy who's got roasting
a pig and lemonade and you go back and
it's the nicest people in the world
and these are the people that they
accuse of being white supremacists and
racists exactly
exactly and that and i'm telling you man
it's like i'm not gonna lie i stereotype
the hell out of that guy and i'm like
nah this dude's gonna chop me up and
wear my face man
he's gonna do like leather face or
something you know and he gave you a he
gave you a slab of a mutton and
oh man good time these people bro good
time you know
and you know when i when i started to
see that you know i thought i thought
about it for a while i thought about you
said you know what i'm going to go
to texas right and i honestly believe
that like if i didn't go to that trump
rally in january 28th i wouldn't be for
one i wouldn't be running for congress
and two
it wouldn't have revitalized my hope
that we can still save new jersey wait
so so you went to a trump rally what's
the trump rally january 28th this year
this year the one that he had in january
wildwood yeah massive massive one
yeah i really wanted to go i didn't make
it act because it was it was they i
couldn't get in
well to be fair we didn't get it either
but going down there meeting everybody
yeah so that's that's that's so funny
thing my friend i'll even tell you that
story because that's literally the
inception of this whole
congressional run anyway right at this
point no intention of running nothing
like that
but i wanted to be involved in the
political scene and see what's going on
right so
my friend good friend for instance like
child my friend randy
he's like hey man you should uh let's
let's go to the trump rally
you know he's coming to new jersey let's
go and he's one of those guys who's like
a low-key trump supporter he doesn't
want anybody to know but like now
everybody knows he's like you know high
key trump now
but like so he's like let's go to the
rally i'm like okay cool we try and go
the day comes around
hey i gotta work i can't make it and i'm
like oh nah man we gotta go at this
point i'm already gung-ho i'm like
already voted for the dude like he's
coming to new jersey like there's no way
and he's like get in contact with dr
castillo he was like you know the doctor
right there on mill street go
go over there he's going down there with
the republican um the hispanic
republican national assembly
go down there with them right so it's
the first time i actually meet dr
castillo i'd seen him on posters knew
all about the guy but
you know never met him so while we're
going down there you know he's probably
thinking like you know he's probably
just like you know regular democrat dude
from the hood who's curious right
whatever yeah so we have a little short
small talk we didn't really talk any
trump stuff till we get there
we get to the we get to this place man
and first off it's like 27 degrees it's
brick it is freezing out there man
you know but there's thousands of people
man yeah
hundreds of thousands and i was i was
blown away because i was like
what in new jersey and and mind you some
came from you know
pennsylvania and probably other places
as well too but even still
there had to have been like 120 000
people out there wow there was a lot of
people bro like the way the
the so we get to the rally
they had a park right right outside the
convention center right
and the entire park was full from fence
to fence like in this little snake
formation kind of thing right by the
time you get out of the park
you come down one block you go up three
blocks you cross the street and then
there's a huge parking lot in the
wildwood center and there's a massive
snake chain
going all the way through the parking
lot until you got into the front we got
there at 11.
by the time we got to the front i was
100 people away from the front
it was like 8 o'clock all right at this
point right trump's about to go on
door's locked hundred people and can't
get in i'm like okay great whatever
you know it is what it is right now
there's there's a part that i skipped
actually the most significant part that
happened is
i did an interview with a guy named
andrew dadansky he's like some
he does like a lot of these uh little
reports and stuff and while i'm doing
this report
dr castillo's sitting there next to me
the entire time and the whole time we're
there i didn't really speak much right
so i'm kind of just giving my opinion
that video is also on my uh my
uh my instagram i'm kind of just talking
about different things foreign policy
whatever right and um then kaylee
mcinenny at the time i had no idea who
she was right
um she wasn't the press secretary we're
sitting down we're we're standing in
front of this uh
this line waiting for steaks and i see
kaley coming down the
side of this um uh the little barricade
whatever she's got the microphone she's
like putting into the crowd trying to
get people to talk people like oh no my
boss if my boss sees me
you know i can't talk about this
whatever right so she gets to where i'm
at and she's like oh well i guess that's
it i guess we're gonna put the uh we're
gonna put the cameras away i'm like no
no i'll talk
at first i was just messing with her
right yeah and it's just her she's got a
like a big black fur coat and these two
massive dudes with you know suits on
i just kind of put two and two together
like that these guys are secret service
i thought she's just
you know you know journalists with two
homeboys like protecting her you know
and um she's like oh you really want to
talk so you sure i'm like yeah let's
talk about like you're not fake news
though right hahaha no we're not fake
news
i'm like i'm like what organization are
you with and she's like oh we're just
here supporting trump just like you
she didn't tell me your name didn't tell
me anything like that she's like oh so
you want to say something to the
president
so then i said what i said you know
that's oh you go on trump's page you'll
find that um
that that post i said i said you know
trump good guy whatever woo
i said that and then right after all
that was done like everybody crown's
like man you said something that
was on my mind but you just you just
worded in such a way that i never could
i was like oh okay that's cool
dr castillo says hey bill comey pulled
him to the side right
say hey bill i think you should run for
congress
there it is and i'm like what and i'm
like he's like no no seriously i'm you
know i'm running in cd5 i ran in
district nine before against pascaro
um the only reason why i didn't win is i
wasn't able to i wasn't able to get the
younger
vote and i wasn't able to acquire the
african-american vote and it was like
you are different
you know he was like this whole time i'm
thinking you're a democrat and he's like
you're a super conservative and i had no
clue and it's like
you've got a mind about all these
different kinds of things i feel like if
you polish yourself up and you kind of
you know put your things in the right
way like you could do really well in
politics so he said run
and i said well if you help me and you
kind of guide me through this process i
was like yeah
he's like i'm already running in the
fifth you're running the nine full tag
teammate we'll go in you know
it'll be great and i'm like all right
doctor let's do it all right so let's
let's do this race man and we're sitting
down
and uh we're watching trump on the jumbo
screen while he's talking
and i just got like filled with like
this
this just like yes let's do this kind of
feeling man because i'm watching this
guy and i'm like yo
all these people came from all across
the state and the surrounding areas to
come and see this guy
in freezing cold weather and we're still
here this guy zero days in politics
isn't a politician yeah he's
accomplished so many things in under
three years
and i'm like if he could do it and if
aoc was an
absolute airhead can do it
i mean she won i mean i'll give her
credit for that you know youngest
congresswoman everything
i'll give her credit for that but like
if she could do it
there's nothing stopping me from doing
it nothing you know
and i'm smarter than her okay i'm not
trying to tune my heart so i'm like
confidence is good yeah i'm smarter than
her so i'm like i'm like if i can do
that
and the president was able to do that
and i know i've got pretty good ideas
i'm gonna i'm gonna seriously take dr
castillo up on his offer yeah and then
from then on you know the following day
went home built that website that we're
looking at right now
started making the logos on photoshop
and just started like you know just
doing the whole thing
and we can't i just started running
started running you're not it's an
uphill battle though bro
it is you know but but here's the thing
man the way i look at it is like and i
personally believe that i'm gonna win
the reason why i believe this is because
nobody knows what this guy's platform is
right i've constantly called them out to
debate lots of other people have called
them out to debate even the democrats
don't do it
the democrats even called him out to
debate the only person he agreed to
debate was a guy named al basaran right
alpacard
which i think was a horrible um campaign
move was on his website it was like you
know
congress deserves a formal or former
illegal alien
in congress and i'm like that's a
horrible slogan you know to put cause
like his he he championed himself on you
know
um i'm a turkish immigrant came here
illegally and i'm in congress and i
should be in congress but he was like
off the wall socialist this guy wow
you know him and another lady zena
spazakis off the wall socialist i
challenged both of them to a debate
because i'm like listen i'm in the
primary with you guys i'm a republican
who didn't want to talk to me i'll say
yeah i'll maybe debate you
pascrell accepted al basaran's
uh request to debate and i'm like of
course you're going to debate the
socialist you know
of course you debate him and like you
know you just pull up the immigration
thing and it's it's over right
but then he only agreed to do it at a
virtual forum
he didn't want to do it in person so
apple's like no no let's do it in person
and i'm pretty sure op would have really
gave it to him he would probably get he
would have raised a lot of really good
points because
despite all the socialist stuff he's a
very smart guy you know you know he
knows quite a few things
you know um and he wanted to do it by
his rule so he didn't want to do that so
i said okay of all the people you're
gonna debate you're gonna debate him so
i said all right i'm gonna debate bill
paschall
and i started going after him he didn't
want to respond to any of the things so
now
i'm kind of trying to give this guy the
biggest headache in the world you know
um i know recently he just had
he had a um uh i believe it was a stent
he had to get put into his heart he has
like heart problems
he's 83 years old man bill pascal 83
years old
wow he's 83 years old he's got some
heart issues right now and i'm like man
listen if you want to run in politics
this is a hard game and it's like i'm
serious about what i want to do i'm not
going to let you just sit there and
coast and
and do nothing you're not going to pull
a ruth bader ginsburg on me bro you know
what i mean it's like i'm going to
i'm going to take it to you so you know
i'm showing up at his fire department
that he built
and this was about two days ago it was
in front of his fire department hey bill
we're out your fire department come out
and debate me
you know we'll put the bait right here
in front of the uh in front of the fire
department or whatever
so now i'm gonna i'm gonna show up at
all of his offices i got people calling
his office people sending emails
hey listen pascrell come out and debate
stop running away you know i mean 23
years you talk about how
you've done so much and what really
pisses me off is he's from patterson
he's from paterson originally right he
chants oh i grew up in patterson i know
what it's like
no you don't because you're not doing
anything if you knew what it was like
you wouldn't allow it to be in a
situation that it's in
you know he doesn't want to talk about
any facts because he knows i'm going to
hold his feet to the fire
he can't pull the whole black lives
matter nonsense with a guy like me
because i live here
all right he can't pull the whole
anti-trump you're
you're a racist if you support trump
because i support trump all the moves
that he would have used on any of the
other republican candidates he can't use
on me so it's
best for me to just stay in the basement
and be basement bill stay away from this
guy
all right i love i love the backfiring
identity politics oh yeah
he knows it he knows it he knows it
that's the only thing there's no
rationale for it that's what i was
i was thinking before like when i was
talking about how kanye west said you
know you have to be a democrat or else
yeah because they like to use the black
community they say that they're
they're the ones who are going to speak
on your behalf and fight for you
absolutely
and i'm like like i said earlier man if
that guy wants to come out and play that
game
well he just lost the argument because
let's play that game not not only are
you from a predominantly black area but
you're literally a black dude
so like why would i support him why
would i believe he knows anything about
what's happening in your community if he
thinks that's the that's the issue that
needs to be fought for
i'm gonna look to you billy i'm gonna
ask you all right you you take you take
the reigns
yeah because you both seem to agree
right right and he's not he's not gonna
he's he's not gonna try and debate that
kind of stuff you know
and you you know i'm i'm kind of sick
and tired of
of people using the black community as
the useful idiots you know same way that
the socialists took over with the useful
idiots doing the same thing right now
with the african-american community in
black lives matter
yeah and i'm sick and tired of that
we're not scapegoats you know we've
already been through enough we've
already got all kinds of nonsense we've
been dealing with slavery
segregation all kinds of nonsense and
now you want to use to keep pushing your
democrat policies that put us in a
situation in the first place
and you're going to say that you're for
us black lives matter get out of my face
with that
that's why you know there are some
things candace owens has said that i've
disagreed with
but for the most part that that's why i
was mentioning like you and kimberly for
instance people like candace owen the
hodge twins
uh you know terrence williams i don't i
i think there's a lot of people
who you know i think it's obvious they
use identity politics they make money
off it they make a career off of it
and now you've finally got a bunch of
people who are actually black standing
up
asserting themselves saying here's what
we want here's what we want to do like
literally what you just said
tired of having your community be the
scapegoat what do they call you
white supremacists racists that's the
craziest nonsense or even they'll try to
call you're an uncle tom
i'm like oh oh really that's the case i
watched that dot you see the documentary
fantastic documentary by the way
i didn't even realize um uh herman cain
yeah his story was amazing yeah man i
didn't even know it was that deep
when he was like i was trying to figure
out why i wasn't getting paid enough
money and my boss says well he's got a
degree
so i got me a degree and i was like yeah
yeah dude i like that
so i'll tell you what man look i grew up
on the south side i come second
generation mixed race family
i grew up with stories about civil
rights air and all this stuff and all
the things that
were hard fought and now i'm seeing this
this insane racism from the left
but i've absolutely always been someone
who's
detested racism detested white
supremacists and all that stuff
and now now i find myself in this
interesting position where as someone
who's grown up
hearing stories from my grandparents
from my parents about how life was what
was life like in the country before
civil rights
i see a bunch of black people actually
standing up saying we're going to run
and they're conservatives right and
they're getting they're getting crapped
all over by all these progressives
and i'm like but wait hold on a minute
this is exactly what
we were all fighting for so that people
could be protect people's
were judged based on their their their
character not the color of their skin
right
and for some reason they're trying the
it's the democrats trying to maintain
the inverse of that
right but but to be fair you look at the
the the
diversity i guess of the parties yeah
you look at the republican party you got
a whole bunch of white dudes you look at
the democrat party you got a whole bunch
of you know you've got minority women
you've got some minority dudes you've
got some white people
but it's all about fall in line behind
our ideas
or you're a racist and will try and tear
you down right and now that they've got
people who
who are diverse standing up saying well
we disagree with your ideas
they're trying to use all these tactics
to destroy it's
it's hypocrisy and i think it proves
they never actually cared about
actual diversity they never cared about
the actual melting pot of this country
they just cared about using that image
their their their uh
their support for black lives matter in
my opinion is skin deep quite literally
they want they want to make sure that
they have the support of people based on
what they look like instead of
convincing people their ideas are good
so they'll make they'll make they'll
make the show of it
they say this all the time like why
don't you take a look at the you know
when it was uh the state of the union
you see all the democrats and you've got
different people of different colors and
genders and you look at the republicans
and it's mostly like white dudes and
some white women
and they use that against them and i'm
like okay i agree then i'll tell you
what start
supporting people of different races
different genders whatever
correct who aren't white then no no they
call candace owens a white supremacist
they call ben shapiro and nazi they call
him
but they call you trying to smear you as
a conspiracy theorist too right
and i'm like you it just ties back to
your
your opponent is 83 and he's saying
black lives matter and it's like that's
the stupidest argument
yeah and he hasn't done a single thing
about it man thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you